[Musique]
un premier prix pour une réflexion sur
la paternité une autoproduction de 14
minutes
le jury du festival a récompensé pripyat
le film de olivier cavellat c'est son
premier prix voilà j'ai en scène
quelques festivals et là c'est son
premier prix nous très content j'ai eu
un fils qui s'appelle louis il ya six
ans aujourd'hui pas aujourd'hui à
quelques quelques mois est en fait moi
contrairement à fabien moi je me suis
posé des questions avant de faire un
enfant
voilà et samaa j'ai mis un certain temps
à trouver des réponses savoir est ce que
je voulais un enfant ou pas voilà et le
film part de la part de cette
interrogation face à lui 17 autres films
étaient en compétition des réalisations
de moins de 16 minutes pour cette 7e
édition du festival trois heures de
projection avant de longs débats en se
base principalement sur les critères la
qualité de l'image à qualité technique
la qualité du scénario la qualité de jeu
est effectivement on essaie de trouver
un film qui puisse rassembler en fait
tous ces différents points et bien sûr
qu'ils puissent véhicules et de
l'émotion c'est très varié très
éclectique comme d'habitude et voilà on
a de très belles surprises il y avait
pas mal de courts métrages interdit aux
moins de dix ou douze ans donc c'est
probablement
voilà un petit peu moins
un peu moins censure et autocensure et
en tout cas donc on a vraiment laissé
libre cours à la création et on sait
absolument pas interdit quoi que ce soit
en tout six autres prix ont été remis
lors de cette journée celui du public a
récompensé pourquoi lui de khamis un
gars ou les langues